[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone i'm clem co-founder and ceo
at talking face
here we work really hard to democratize
good machine learning and i'm super
happy to introduce you to our experts
hi i'm lysander i'm leading the open
source team at hugging face i've been at
hugging face for close to three years
now and so as we pivoted to open source
i was very involved right from the start
and so it started with the transformers
library three years ago but as we
evolved and started having more
open source repositories i was also
involved in them
and so over the past three years i've
been a core maintainer of transformers
but also involved in other of our open
source efforts um at hugging face hi i'm
thomas wolfe i'm a co-founder and chief
scientist at hugging face where i've
been creating a few libraries like
transformers data sets and the big
science project
and i also recently quoted the book with
lewis and leondro and all the library
and the open source tool we have a
talking face
hi
i'm lucille i'm a machine learning
engineer at urging face i did an
engineering school at central paris that
i pursue with a master degree in
research in applying mathematics at
ens prairie circle so hey i'm silver and
i'm a research engineer at talking face
where i'm a co-mington of the
transformers library and the accelerate
library and i've developed the urging
phase course hi i'm victor san i'm a
research scientist here at hacking face
on a day-to-day basis i mostly work on
large-scale foundational models for
machine learning hi everyone my name is
niels i'm from belgium and i'm working
as a machine learning engineer at
hackingface i discovered an algorithm on
twitter from google and then i decided
to challenge myself
try to re-implement it and add it to
hacking phase transformers
so that's what i did i started from
scratch
taking a model that was implemented in
tensorflow and make it available in
pytorch such that everyone in the world
can use it through hacking phase
transformers ever since i've been adding
new and
nicer models to the transformers library
hi i'm canal i'm a machine learning
engineer here at hugging face i come
from a research background
doing my master's at mit
researching how to predict political
bias and factuality
within news media also studied this this
problem with uh under the lens of
explainability as well
um and used many hugging face models
during my time in that research which
kind of naturally led me to work here as
well
my exposure to hucking face before
a lot of the models in tech that i was
doing my research on during my master's
um
i'm now working with a lot of the people
that developed those models which is
incredible i talk to them on like a
week-to-week basis and i can ask them
questions that i have
um
you know get my own kind of version and
run down of what state of the art in the
field that they're studying is
i just think that's just super cool
i guess it's like now my job to
ask those questions and present those
results to the customers we work with in
the expert acceleration program
how often do you get that perspective
with a business flare
um or just out of curiosity necessarily
like if you're not you know involved in
the research community you can't really
ask those questions to anybody like this
nailed it